eleven hours left of the 2019 autumn
marathon I've actually already played a
few games and started 13 hours ago
joining back in the games I play it I
didn't stream I played them from my
phone okay
ooh playing a strong player okay first
game of the stream let's play start with
a London probably just stick with my my
main basically my main blitz repertory
I'm sure I'll mix up the openings
throughout the tournament though II six
play a four is preventing b5 just
playing restrictively preventing b5
preventing e5 there should be seven
Bishop d3 maybe I'll play Queen e2 and
go for a 5/5 here looks interesting
there's not h5 Bishop g5 might be
sacking upon maybe I'll play this move
first
yeah 9h 5 is actually annoying after a 5
hello to people in the chat I was try
and stay focused yeah I was expecting a
lower rated player this first game so e5
still not h5 and there's Bishop takes
off three problems black wants to play
e5 himself
I probably have to allow it hmm Bishop
h2 yeah keeping a positional I'll leave
the tension in the center some pressure
on e4 let's play my knight b3 give black
the choice of what he wants to take it
takes nothing
maybe f3
I'm just undermining the bishop at any
time black can grab the bishop here ok
damage is my structure but allows me to
keep my bishop here also now the C file
is half open I'll put the bishop on c4
now there is a two second increment
which will be useful especially if I get
lower on time the King h1 is natural
hello to everyone
zoo is this some fan aroni is back dr.
drew mate I hit plunger thanks for
subbing I appreciate your sub this is my
rook belong on d1 Queen d2 maybe
like bring the bishop back to f4 there's
a p5 interesting it's a tense position
oh we could trade more so take stakes
here we got very positional bring the
King to e3 of Queen oh I'll keep it safe
I think this is easier to play with less
time the pawn on h4 pawns actually want
to be on dark squares but how to improve
further my knight should be somewhere
better start with g3 yeah where's my
knight go
[Music]
not sure what to do here and I could
trade everything I guess I'll trade
everything and just simplify further
this could be pretty Josh oh so be Oh am
i losing a pawn would be threes attacked
I guess I got careless that's not good I
might be losing here I have to try and
fight on time takes okay I for giving
box some choice this is not looking good
I have this Bishop versus night
imbalance
we've some tension okay I want to go for
the breakthrough g4 just want to make a
past each pawn I guess it doesn't
accomplish much though setting up a trap
if takes I might be winning okay now
it's still interesting because I'm
threatening to chocolate bishop oh the
blocks gonna win the race it's kind of
sad still some hope maybe not much hope
night each three no let's do this first
promise Queen each six I can't make
progress
oh I flagged so sad John Davis is back
thanks John Davis subbing yet again and
calm info your nips is also back for
three months I was a rough start
[Music]
opponent played well just completely
outplayed me I had one weakness of b3
Fon and after Bishop e6 I'm just I did
not have any way to defend what to do
let's recover no need for hoody
it's got serious a 1520 fourth place is
it safe to put honey into tea of course
just not too much honey let's play this
and let's dessert try and rebound
rebound strong I think the rule is any
opponent below mm I'll berserk play
Bishop c4 Queen e2 now it's telling this
in my previous stream but I was like
trying to fall asleep other nights and
on the verge of falling asleep I like
this move order came to mind with Bishop
c4 just early Queen e2 normally you
can't do this against main line periods
but this is a line usually resulting
from the modern and it's pleasant for
whites h3 restricts Bishop g4 and I'll
just Castle and put the work on d1 upon
me 5 is well reinforced welcome Zachary
from YouTube Zachary James Foy hello -
SHhhh Road cats what to do ambition a6
is looming
I think this move some of friends to win
upon takes takes
ecigs
okay feeling comfortable I want to bring
the Knight to e4 I should preserve my
bishop start with c3 but some eventual
night maneuvers could be fun this pawns
attacked probably rook t1 and black is
doing things before b4 c4
oh hi berserk okay I have to play
aggressively for gala deserts let's move
back to g3 yabba's irking is very risky
with increments because I don't have
increment my opponent has increment so I
have to win over the board can't rely on
dirty flagging so Bishop g3 will over
defend the pawn meaning it might allow
494 black is still trying to get into
smooth good morning to David lang gone
and before is interesting I might play
Queen e4 after before sac upon I do not
live on an East Coast live in the
Midwest I'll be back in st. Louis in a
couple days
[Music]
okay before well before it could be
really annoying cuz my queen is actually
pretty short on squares there's a really
weird move after it'd be four to play
Knight f6 um I should not spend too much
time let's go for this and check to the
king and if flock takes on f6 I take
back and the diagonal opens up against
blocks Queen Queen e4 okay it's gonna be
a time scramble
we're both below a minute block
strolling with increments but I'm the
one with an attack this looks fun I just
want to remove the g6 pawn inmates on
each seven whoa three nights I like free
stuff link block was trying to make this
work
but I'll be up a piece in the end the
problem is we're trading Queens it's
still gonna take a long time to convert
this and I only have 30 seconds left
should be enough time just have to play
quickly and simplify and before it could
still come maybe 95 95 will be a fork
any five is playable that's also
playable I'm black expanding I'm 25 so
yeah II for was expected
eh five ah black keeps expanding stop it
let's play this move trying to take on
g6 with Czech have to do a c3 though
black might flag opponent taking a lot
of time it's gonna flag hey I want I'm I
mean black had the two second increments
but I guess it what what's not enough
okay I want a game the first win of the
stream hello to more people Krishna mr.
K mr. K in the chat shout out to mr. K
[Music]
wait what did that say Holley morph do I
go completely insane
let's go completely insane opponent
doesn't want to take okay I'll still go
insane g5 g5 is a good way to wake up in
the morning g4 not sure what's going on
but we're gonna have some fun I might be
down how much am i down only a pawn oh
so polymorph said thanks to your lecture
I went from heating Sicilian to having
best win rates using 93 very nice yeah
93 Sicilian is one of my favorite
openings grand prix attack or close
Sicilian I'm sure I'll get a chance to
play it this tournament and I am Avalon
thanks for subbing for 3 months what to
do here I have some temporary some
temporary initiative or not initiative
but just some active play develop
preventing ii4 a z pawn can't really
move except it just moved so white
sacking upon to try and I guess complete
developments
we might just be trading everything I
could take the night or I could play d5
but then g4 hangs like f5
let's take we'll have a slightly more
positional game takes takes knight c6
maybe takes in h5 ok equal material
might versus Bishop Knight c6 is looking
nice play King King d7 our queenside
castling
oh no d5 is coming maybe a six looks
reasonable we're gonna have some
reckoning gonna take some effort to try
and win this
why preserving the bishop makes sense
not sure what to do maybe King f8 I
think the King belongs on g7 keep
southpaw undefended and get out of this
pin
it's okay it could be interesting I have
to calculate lines with d5 so rookie it
takes takes t 5b v takes takes it's kind
of weird but let's do it
fighting for the only open file on the
board and now's the time for d5 some
idea 95 to c4 yeah maybe night c4 here
very positional yeah after the trade now
be b2 slightly backwards except not
anymore
play a 5 I could take but I want to
create some weakness play a 5 I can play
a four even I think I should play for
how the problem is takes takes rook b1
[Music]
maybe that's not so bad yeah let's go
for this I'm gonna have a passive rook
rook b6 here
I think rook b6 makes sense I don't want
to allow pawn b6 if take stakes I have
the threat of rook b2 to win g2 I want
to play d5 I am aware that my opponent
could be watching the stream but I mean
I deal with it I tried to deal with it
d5 here I mean some moves even if my
opponent knows it's coming it's not
gonna affect too many things
okay so c4 is defended a pawn still
hanging but whenever white takes money
for I take here ooh oh this is
interesting endgame am i winning this I
feel like this should be winning for
white or for uh for black this takes
takes I enter the box so here here I
have the path C pawn and I'll make a
pass eight pospone on the other side
pretty sure this is winning trusting my
instincts if it's a slower game I trying
to just calculate everything but I'm
pretty sure the my cos C pawn and my
King side majority is better than these
two connected passed pawns my King was
like slightly further away it would be
losing yeah so that's some move but I'll
bring the King in so idea is to break
through eventually with f5
you start with f5 I'll start with this
clicking here might be some important
line where I like I checked the king to
gain one tempo so I'm realizing if I try
and break through it could be tricky
let's start with f5
yeah like here checking the king or even
they're there they're gonna move around
for a little bit
gain some time I have no time to
calculate though there it takes there
there there I think this is working not
sure though it's complicated
well comes down to one tempo King c3
then f4 I think I'm gonna for them takes
some moves c3 first yeah King III c3 c3
could maybe be pre moved to but don't
think I want to risk that
now F for breaking through love an
endgame okay Wow dr. X doc thanks for
subbing hello to extreme duo welcome
back yeah I mean I wasn't going to
calculate like so precisely from the
moment we traded rooks but I was
interesting finish yeah I just moved
around with the King to try and gain
enough time in h4 I think it's this
point winning okay back to turn mix so
the first goal is to break into the top
thousand and then someday the top
hundred I'll bizarre following the
berserk enroll I'll play e4 I might see
three Sicilian I forgot who mentioned it
earlier but they were saying thanks in
regards to this opening I'm gonna play a
slightly different line Bishop g7 d4 for
a long time I used to Castle
oh is this line maybe five - remember
the the prep here there is a Aronian
Grisha or nipple Miyaichi I forget the
exact players but that feature Knight
takes d4 Queen b6
what's my what's the preparation here c3
I guess c3 it's not looking the most
impressive though okay some some sort of
position I am down upon kind of reminds
me of this myth Mora is 94
I have to move a lot quicker going for
more long-term compensation hey sock
attack is back
it actually streamed for this is my
third day in a row trying to keep a
streak okay I'm gonna get the bishop
hair maybe some sneaky queen f2 idea
threatening this well my opponents see
the threats also how does Bach defend
against a threat maybe queen h5 but the
Queen's a bit awkward there I mean let's
start with G for threatening to think
that such Queen trap threatening Bishop
[Music]
b6u Black has to retreat the Queen Wow
Queen trap right no scores for the Queen
all these squares are covered
pawns doing work most every pawn is
participating in the Queen trap that's
nice does that do anything now that does
something
yeah there's Bishop d4 okay so I'm up a
piece it should be enough bring the King
in still have some potential attack that
rook should be on d1
oh you want me to play 93 feel like I
played that once and it did not go so
well and then I blamed it on people this
game was the knight c3 Sicilian
interesting gambit within the grand prix
attack what does this move let's start
with rook d1 questioning the Knights
I'll take a pawn there's ninety five
fancy move leveraging the pin chasing
the king and that f6 incoming some
mating net where's it mate maybe this
move if takes an IgA track h6 mates ah
that's a good move let's take play 98
searching for the win
that's 17 seconds everything stuck in
blacks position okay that's what I like
to see threatening me than one okay good
choice by black does that meat that's
meats okay some nerves towards the end
there you could try Knight a3 Sicilian
ooh
well not as black maybe I'll place the
sealing this black though yeah
Sicilian time plate d6 let's play a
dragon or night or I forgot some is
there let's play a true again neither
what scares me too much theory
[Music]
hi dragendorff me at some point I'll
play a six but we have we have a
mainline dragon so against the sign I
think black should take and play Bishop
e6 taking advantage of the fact white
hasn't played Bishop c4 and then the
idea is Queen a5 rakov c8 someday B Phi
before try and use the bishops along
with arrows it's a pretty pleasant
position to play now do I play b5
immediately so there's Knight takes b5
you play rook a be 8
[Music]
let's play were kb8 I think I have time
like Bishop d3 kind of signifies it
lights not acting so quickly but now
White's trying to act quickly I always
have to keep in mind like the Bishop h6
resource can never mind not gonna happen
anytime soon
do I take on e4 this work
I don't know Bishop takes e4 take on c3
or no do I play b4 b4 it's probably the
the critical move takes takes let's do
it
there's a line actually where Bishop h6
is relevant
after takes takes uh takes takes takes
takes takes Bishop h6 and then wins back
material this might happen and then in
the end I'm still gonna be down a pawn
or it's gonna be equal material I guess
I'll find out so there should be six
immediately it's probably the way to go
it was king b1 I win the Queen for free
oh there's a cool move coming up there's
a really cool move Bishop a - look at
this move oh but this is maybe it
doesn't work does it not work Bishop a -
King d1 I want to go for this rook be
one King here and then rook takes h1 it
looks like I went a piece but after it
takes I have no way of stopping the pond
from promoting that's so depressing
but should a to almost just wins on the
spot but it doesn't can you wait to make
this work I guess I could just take
first see what white is doing yeah I'll
take first now I'm I am threatening
vision a to and if king d1 then in rugby
one so it's the balls in White's court
to come up with some defense here and
meanwhile I should probably count the
pawns materials equal assuming I take
the rook at some point I only see one
defense which I'm not gonna say oh I
didn't see that I guess that's another
defense jack of the trade oh that's a
said opening I have thought that was
referring to chess opening but that's
the opening bracket ya snack attack
thanks for sharing that
yeah the discord link is in the chat do
I take first or do I play Bishop a2 and
whatever I do I should move quicker
maybe in this move just getting ready to
try and win upon it's probably not the
best move but it is a move okay I'll
check Wow King a one now I should
probably take the rook unless I want to
be extra tricky I'm gonna be extra
tricky I don't want to give away my
dark-squared bishop because the King's
cornered on a dark square and the bishop
could be the piece that eventually mates
as Bishop e5 just made into are made in
three because there's this move but its
mates like the the White has no defense
the C pawn is pinned the dragon Bishop
has come to life okay I was not
expecting that finish I thought it was
gonna be like a long grinding endgame
that was nice okay i rebounded from the
initial loss playing nadya Ned I'll play
e4 again but yeah thank you
Jack of the trade for the 750 bits I
will say my discord like isn't so active
but I think there is like a handful of
people that that discuss in multiple
channels oh I forgot the night a3
Sicilian I'll save that for the future
my night is now misplaced on c3 you guys
have to keep reminding me there was one
year at US Open it was like 2000 2008 or
2009 Alexander Shibboleth played 93
Sicilian like multiple times and had
good results with it was it's playable
and it's a way to get the point out of
their comfort zone
I'm already happy like there's some so
many attacking ideas it's like classic
run Grand Prix eventually king h1
probably bring the other looking Ahmad
likes just saying there's a knight a3
Sicilian question mark exclamation
points I mean there's a mighty a3
everything there can be a knight a3
caro-kann not a three Italian maybe not
a three Grob okay I'm just going for me
do I play this immediately because
there's Queen b6 mm-hmm
maybe I should start with King h1
usually a just a necessary move and King
is now safe I don't think that a3
caro-kann would make any sense cuz black
plays d5 and what is it like doing on 83
but like this position I guess my night
would be arguably more useful on 83
because then I can come to c4 c3 it's
doing nothing okay maybe there's ideas
this and this but the main ideas are
Bishop h6 or Bishop f4 maybe Bishop f4
followed by e 5 f6 ok this is
interesting I have row gauge 3
immediately h5 I could also take on e7 I
think I'll start with this
as I want to remove blacks main defender
and also prevent h5 and now I'm just
getting ready for a rogue h3 Queen e5
let's play rook h3 he'll take and play
Queen g7 so maybe Bishop f4 changed my
mind
trying to trap the Queen mmm I was a
nice sip of tea also this is a nice soon
to be fork the bishop fork it's gonna be
sad giving away my bishop his was one of
my main attackers but that's the circle
of life I'll win the exchange or not I'm
not winning the exchange I guess I'm not
winning the exchange but I didn't win a
pawn
let's take there's night 92 now but then
Queen digs B - lets just improve the
rook okay I'm still happy I'm up upon I
have a battery lights a bit loose
now a three-night h3 makes for very
dubious Heisenberg variation of the
King's gambit accepted we're digging a
very deep hole into new opening theory
there was a game in the protest League
think was Carlsen vs j EV had started
night h3 night h6 fresh position after
you move one okay this is very typical
like attacking finish pretty sure I've
had this finish at least once in like
over the board game the same sort of
setup whether it takes h5 and then Queen
g7 mates
okay let's play a plane I have six
haven't play the Buddha past the stream
I guess it'll have to wait
[Music]
III III is playable on apply b5 C five
fish should be seven maybe here just be
six just being kind of the bishop
complete development white wants to play
e4 so I'll play play Knight 94 or c5 b
c5 this also restricts efore now Queen
c7 can't complain I have not played the
Carroll Khan I'll try and play a range
of openings no Carol Kahn has been
suggested multiple times I think by the
same person but I'll try and fit that
one in still have to play that night a3
Sicilian and I should play a time out of
for the banana let's play rook rook c8
looks reasonable oh it loses a pawn
though but opponent doesn't take it such
quality chess
I just want to attack how do i attack he
worked yet i should improve before I
attack
Icelandic gambit I keep forgetting what
that is
it starts with Knight f6 Scandinavian
though right or it's when you go to
Iceland and then you go broke because
food cost so much but the scenery is so
nice but it's probably worth it
okay so I'm attacking the bishop and now
I'm attacking other bishop and how the
night as well also the pawn pawns
attacked four times this Knights kind of
pinned but that's okay
GU three nights of three nights this is
not the best quality game my opponent
miss a free pawn earlier miss a d4 thing
hanging but it's trying to fight this
looks like more material yeah if takes I
was excited to play this move
threatening the rook and threatening
meet okay 20 move victory climbing my
way towards greatness before d5 no 64 I
think there's a move missed but I
understand what you mean Josiah it's
likeif or no let's play the UM the
hillbilly queen eh 5 hillbilly attack
time oh it's not gonna flight 93
hillbilly is a lot more fun and smell
the bad opening for blitz I'd used to
play f3 and in some sense act upon and
do stuff later with castling queenside
the first time I ever saw this I think
it was Carlson's like after blitz and
Carlson has played this in a few like
worldlets championships I think with
like reasonable success
what to do here in 95 maybe 95 looks
interesting because of the tax off seven
and ideas of g4g for just trapped the
bishop there's g5 though but then Bishop
takes g5 this could get really crazy
really quickly
oh the problem G for tonight takes g4
yeah that's more of a problem maybe just
Bishop t2
I'm not sure what to do here each three
perhaps looks so slow a g5 is coming
Queen f2 is a move you'll play Queen f2
there's some idea like I was thinking g5
can be met with takes and then takes
that's a move Bishop e5 but there's no
g4 worries like c4 here okay not the
most impressive starts but there's still
something to play for now I have my
files just have to make use of them yeah
g5 expected I'll play Bishop e3 getting
ready to just castle but do I want a
castle
there's g4 immediately let's play g4 I'm
just gonna hold off casting go for the
immediate attack trying to destroy this
pawn formation Allen basic thanks for
stopping by thanks for your comments
this is not going to be a 24 hour stream
I've joined the tournament 13 hours late
it is a 24 hour tournament though I'm
only playing a portion of it
yeah 95 is a good move maybe Queen e2
defending the pawn aligning with the
night if takes and probably takes here
b5 each file is open the box like very
solid ok 94 I'm trying to poke and prod
targeting g5 at six can't really ever be
played with my bishop aligned with with
stuff Wow Bishop takes should take c4
unexpected it's playable but now each 7
is not guarded so the dream is to do
this he wants to play Knight h4
[Music]
so Bishop takes B to sort with c3
I've worked d1i Brooke h5 interesting
bishop g3 King f1 just attacking g5 not
so easy for black to defend Bishop d4
perhaps I should I take I could throw a
rock to you one not sure what to do
b5 is interesting maybe you'll play e5
it looks weird but the idea is to use
this diagonal up d1 to move a lot
quicker start with this
I think the Queen wants to be on e4
[Music]
interesting oh that's a good move have
to take I'm in trouble
Oh black had an IG - and I'm defending
my against Knight G - but it's still
really ugly down upon and this night's
so strong I have to do this probably try
and survive this so little time
expecting takes and probably 95 but I'll
try and walk my king in Queen e7 I can
take here
oh no let's do this
oh this is really bad I'm getting mated
I might be ooh
everything's defended of the past a pawn
I want to play a six Oh tricky move play
this move I want to trade Queens and
then win the endgame what does black to
black kind of has to trade Queens may be
crazy fights yeah I have to use my king
now let's take your first defend
this is tricky where doesn't like go
King a4 looks solid am I gonna win this
I'm winning this can't celebrate too
early the Knights kind of annoying still
but I think I'm pretty safe reading this
now there we go
what a game how they how am i winning
this or the game
well survived that's I mean I was
getting smashed but I kept not getting
mated and it kind of worked they as sort
of an opening gone wrong maybe my
opponent got a little bit carried away
with me being and time pressure okay
that's a tournament 693 its 8:55 p.m. I
forget when I started the stream I think
it was around 8:00 so it's been about an
hour okay all berserk it's some maybe
I'll have a 93 Sicilian another
caro-kann let's play two nights attack
wait did I say p.m. or maybe I didn't
specify its 8:55 a.m. I'm on Central
Time whoa it's Nicola Stoughton thanks
so much Nicola and there's different
definitions of greats but ok it was
great in some way ok have to remember
that I'm bezoar King I have no
increments but I have knights and I have
the bishop here now play d4
I bet prizes probably bragging rights
and the fame I don't think there's
monetary prizes I do think there's like
badges in your Li chest profile or like
ritual trophies and Nicola thanks for
subbing
thanks so much Nicola for all the
supports in 10 months
so I have two bishops start with a three
Oh No let's check start with Bishop do i
do Bishop d2 targeting the Queen
I know c3 I guess a3 okay I have to
speed up the tempo opponent does not
want to allow me to castle the inside so
maybe I'll Castle kingside a king should
be safe on g1 looks kind of risky though
just delaying making commitments some f5
ideas yeah castling going for a rook a
e1 and then f5 try and attack trying to
attack on the same side on Castle
44 seconds g5 is also an idea that kind
of shuts things down opponent taking
time I'm talking upon I don't care about
my queen side pawns I care about
attacking and I backing off all the
pawns on the Queen side she this move
does defendant Bishop but okay I'm
threatening to take on he six an e6 pawn
is pinned to the bishop on e7 yeah
that's the best move let's play Queen d3
I wanted to play Bishop f4 but I do not
want to Queen trade so now I'm
threatening Bishop f4 locks a bit
awkward I'm down the pawn that's okay
I hit her b12 keep in mind rugby one
opponent getting low on time - but
opponent has increments
now let's start by taking maybe d5 d6
coming yeah I want to get in d6 c4 is
interesting but then I probably just
take okay big time advantage I think
blacks gonna flag let's not hang a
bishop let's play this safety first
the flag that's the second time of
ponent flags against me buzzer King yes
to second increment is still not much
buzzer again please 5 this time staffer
gambits 591 whoa
this is attempted Cochrane gambit but
probably just dubious because I have
more Knights developed and d5 looks
solid
maybe Queen Queen he Yates I'll get some
early initiative happy with a queen
trade oh it has to make some concession
yeah Queen e2 is one of the concessions
so I'm up a piece I have initiative 94
is interesting on b5 let's play b5 first
see where the bishop moves
I would like to play 94 just show the
dominance with the Knights maybe a 5
justkeep initiative d3 is gonna come
though maybe it takes let's play Bishop
c5 first d3 takes takes I get away with
taking on f2 might be able to actually
yeah even in this line like takes takes
will I have Bishop g4 check and rookie
Yeates it's close to a mating attack oh
I forgot about that
oh that's not good I have this move I
should have 5 ok it's getting weird I
should still be up a piece I could have
taken the rook but that looks a bit
murky ok another one of these time
situations 37 seconds use my hath woven
files it's actually close to mate do
this I think I can do this if King e2
rook e8 his mate was abrupt finish Wow
just a meaning attack in the center
and Saussure playing so much chess these
last few days also working out probably
had the bigger impact hoodie what are
you good to see you back okay
trying to break into the top 500 I've
lost two games as tournament one game
off stream one game on stream playing
mallets I'll beserk again I'll play e4
again I still owe you guys a night a
three Sicilian waiting for a Sicilian
not happening to do ooh
we have okay let's do let's do something
fun Halloween time
Halloween is was it five days away I
think it's five days away yeah
it's a 26 of October did you miss the
caro-kann I played against two Carroll
cons but I have not played that
caro-kann myself but this is the first
Halloween gambit of the stream and
opponents thinking it's always a nice
sign yeah I think this is one of the
main lines Knight g6e 598 I'll see if
doc wants to save the night the thing
about Halloween objectively it's not
that great but it does get the point of
thinking from early on and that's always
a nice thing I think I'll play Bishop e2
just breaking the pin and I'd like to
play Knights b5 at some point yeah
just running the simple fork look at
blacks pieces look at my pawns so
majestic Queen c5 is a move
Queen c5 before mmm what to do
hello its emblem okay I have to stay
focused cuz I'm not entirely sure what
to do here mm-hmm I'll play c3 first I
want to play b4 and just push more pawns
Queen b6 I'll probably play 94 and
repair Bishop e3 looks decent yeah
thanks for the sub emblem for 7 months
I just want to take a sip of tea I'm out
of tea but I have water good
old-fashioned water what does this move
let's take a pond or a bishop
everything's defended so I I won back my
piece but I'm down time so I have to
move a bit more quickly I mean I think
the simple plan is this oh wait I should
defend first let's do this
neither 5ig for another sub Lucas thanks
for subbing actually now the five I have
this move double attacking the knight
and c7 I think there's an interesting
phenomenon when I bezerk and I lose
increment it provokes my opponent like
think for a long time because they have
the increment but then they get a bit
too comfortable I'll put the bishop on
f2 assuming that f5 is played okay but I
still have to move fast
Oh f4 is hanging forgot about that play
g3 maybe I'll make a majestic pawn chain
looks nice Queen is going to be kicked
like Queen c2 hitting the night
expecting d6
let's play Queenie for it's not much
time I want to play f5 just keep pushing
pawns 9f8 expected
okay black socks a piece when I'm up a
piece to h5 8h for mmm let's play h5
okay Knights attack and the rooks
attacked take the rook we need to King
g2 / thumb 93 Oh free Queen that's nice
okay ten seconds should be plenty of
time I could have taken f7 there we go
okay that was a fun game
Halloween strikes again 460 playing zigs
ICO Neves 1853
let's buzzer let's play a Carroll Khan
first caro-kann I'm playing the stream I
have six okay there's been a trend
lately of like playing King f8 h 5 h 4
and doing some attacking stuff I try
that
[Music]
maybe I'll start with King f8 Bishop g4
hey Funke thanks for subbing what does
buzzer - buzzer cuts your time in half
oh I could've taken a free pot I can
still win a free pawn so it basically
gets time odds but if I win the game I
get an extra point in the tournament
standings and what is this name clothes
jar thanks for subbing by Bishop f4
feeling comfortable complete g5 what
else to do
you take let's take Ricky gates and some
plan of just improving my King and
connecting the rooks I still want to
attack eventually by pushing the pawn at
95
yeah Knight g4 could actually be
damaging I don't want to trade Queens
but I might have to no it's not pleasant
okay this is actually gonna be more of a
challenge than I initially thought
of 32 seconds okay okay I'm threatening
the bishop and rook takes e5 maybe not
quite though so rooks defended probably
g5 coming I have to go for some like
hopeful mating attack
I have rook takes e5 yeah let's do it
counter attacking the bishop maybe I
should have taken first 21 seconds don't
know why I put myself in these
situations just crave the adrenaline
rush I want to bring the rook to b3 I
think maybe the King can come in as well
yeah rook b3 coming
I think this works rook takes g5 I have
this move okay that move anyway I should
win the a pawn
there we go tactics promotion tactics f5
meats I'm predicting five meats there we
go close finish I was better but then we
traded Queens and then it got weird
that's probably worse at some points
probably should have flagged cool okay
have a nice streak nice buzzer king
street playing smv k let's play let's
not play caro-kann let's place candy I
have six candy maybe I'll have the
Icelandic I think Icelandic is c4 and
then something the Bishop d7 Bishop c8
here an ideas this and this
okay this looks reasonable you guys
probably played this more often as
whites but the sign is um it doesn't
happen so often opponents thinking it
does feel nice not to worry about like
the increments are not having increment
cuz I didn't bezerk so I went back the
pawn White's committed to f3 which in
some sense is a concession for whites
play c6 reinforcing the Knights
preparing Bishop d6 c4 is coming a 94 is
a good move I could play b5 I will play
b5 trying to discourage c4 some plan of
this getting some setup
hmm especially seven okay it's gonna be
a fights objectively I don't know who's
better relatively balanced actually it's
slightly imbalanced but equal chances
not so clear what White's plan is yes to
pressure this and this I have before
here let's play before ah so that light
will come to e4 okay I'll take with
night and just castle it's gonna be
positional I'll go for like a five
Bishop a six Queen b6 58 trying to apply
pressure from various directions Queen
b6 right away your rook b8 keeping some
tension might see c4 here and see for
probably a five cementing the pawn
Bishop f4 so takes let's play rogue AIDS
yeah White's better here has more space
blocks with a bit passive this move
White's gonna go for his stuff against
my King might be setting up Knight d5
not sure if that accomplishes anything
95 now please this move
going with the original plan of like
rook d8 and pressuring d4 okay now I
have to be very careful to play g6 also
taken than g6 yeah not so comfortable
there's also some b3 idea it's hard to
make that work let's play g6 Bishop g5 I
don't want to allow white to get in b3
it's a problem
the Knight d5 work my d5 some merits to
it
threatening i-5 then there's my g5 9 g5
then g6 let's play Knight g5 looks
really risky like White has any Knight
move threatening made in one except this
Knight move because I take it and then
defend this looks wrong on so many
levels cuz like the pawn is pressuring
so any Queen move will threaten my
Knights I'm not even trying to take is
white would have made in two but I'm
giving white options making white think
and I think my thread is to play off 5
which could be interesting let's play
off 5 there's some line takes takes
takes takes takes King of 7 and of a
piece I might be winning a piece weirdly
enough
but White's gonna have some comp
probably because I'm almost getting
mated oh there is that move interesting
b3
also take uh yeah let's take expecting
takes hmm
yes I'll take here anything else yeah
let's take here things are simplifying
now probably be three oh there's a nice
move
I'm mating by force but Queen takes d4
is just mate right takes rook F on king
h1 64 is it mates I didn't calculate
that like prior over that was just kind
of a long forcing variation oh that's so
nice
I probably had that I have that no I
didn't have it I had to provoke Bishop B
1 so the a one room doesn't help defend
f1 what he came thanks for watching yeah
that was um wasn't nice sort of finish
and I felt like I was in trouble around
here so I really didn't want to play g6
this move was double-edged but got the
job done somehow
yeah f5 was nice
yeahjust law-enforcing sequence yeah
lights probably is white just losing
here because Bishop d3 I have this move
so the bishop is in some sense trapped
all right
dr. tournament at 360
it's like Adam C let's play efore again
what's your biggest tip for 1,700 feet a
player trying to improve positional play
focusing on middle gain study Karpov
schemes when I was I mean when I was
around that rating my coach would just
give me Karpov games usually Karpov
games where he won is black and my coach
would tell me to start after the opening
like move ten to fifteen and just try
and guess every move that Karpov played
and it helped his Karpov has probably
one of the the easiest styles to
understand just in terms of positional
and prophylactic play let's play off
three I was speaking of Karpov I'm not
playing anything like Karpov in this
game if anything black is playing like
Karpov I get away with this
allowing night discoveries let's play
Queen g3 attacking a pawn so this is a
hillbilly attack part two I played this
earlier I think that was a crazy game
earlier that I should have lost but
didn't
now I'm going for the mating attack of
94 here crazy lying like this and rook
p1
let's do it playing like a hillbilly
king h1 interesting so takes and then
Queen takes hmm well what to do
I could play Bishop c1 that's kind of
sad what else to do
now there's Bishop g5 it's probably the
go-to move trying to organize some sort
of attack should probably queenside
castle yeah I won the queenside castle
use a the files which Knight to take
with so you with this Knights Knights
are doing things I might consider Knight
d6 soon to target f7 looks interesting
there's also a Queen h4 Queen H war has
a double threat of Nate also taking here
because tactics so in either six is yeah
I guess expected maybe Queen h4 still
there's h6
hmm let's start with Queen h4
you work f1 just apply a little bit more
pressure the pawns pins if I take that
King G it's a good move
let's take here unfortunately I don't
think I'm getting much not a great
feeling to retreats probably gonna have
to retreat again to Queen g3 every Queen
f2 it's like we enough to I do have my
increments so that's something complete
Defour here maybe c3 Bishop C to do
stuff with the bishop also have C for a
night before I'll play c3 it's still
some potential attack I am setting up a
trap if takes and Bishop h7 now black is
probably threatening to take play Bishop
d3 95 could be crazy 95 too crazy for me
hmm I should probably move quicker rook
b1 not really the move I want to play
though
c4 maybe no let's play rugby 1 Kings
gonna be stuck a little bit in the
center but for the time being I'm not
getting attacked I have 95 I'm trying to
stir up some initiative threatening f7
let's get the Queen to
formulate a battery I'll play Queenie
for Queen D three and a half five G for
this rook should come into - f2 so e5 is
an outpost it's hard for black to remove
the knight actually Knight g6 might
happen
ig6 not happening have to be careful of
this thing - yeah good move let's take
and rook F - so there's pins this pawn
is pinned in two directions this pawn is
also pinned a very risky position was
this bad I'm down the pollen down a lot
of time but I have hope maybe each four
ideas there's a lot of tension this pawn
oh that could be very strong or is it
free bishop the pawns pinned to the rook
because mating ideas there's no Queen C
1 because takes so I think that was a
free bishop oh that's a good move I have
this ooh what do I do here this move ok
it's still complicated King will run to
f3 attacking the Queen King wants to run
away find shelter okay we have an
endgame this makes me feel safer
depending meets it's not quite mate but
it's close
yeah that's a move I think I want to go
for the mating attack just with the King
blocks king is cut off Bishop will
control v1 and the plan is to do this
stuff now let's do this first
wasn't sure about that line mm-hmm this
is tricky and I want to play h4 soon
check oh I have rook rook here that
should save me check okay now I'm going
for meat oh the king is slippery though
Bishop e6 perhaps
okay pretty sure I can win this oh just
as stressful jess is very stressful I
think I was probably losing at some
point I mean I was what much worse for
sure but then opponent gave me
unexpected gifts now for looks crushing
at first attacking the Queen attacking
the bishop but didn't work okay doctor
tournament chess we've in the chats
shout out to chess we've 337 keeping my
beautiful streak takes a while to hit a
hundred points been streaming for about
hour and a half okay
playing brave horsey trying to achieve
the national master me chess blitz title
to break 2200 hopefully not gonna happen
with this game
93 is happening with this game John
Davis better still be here this was John
Davis's idea I think uh what do I do now
maybe this move that's the point of
night 83 right just bring the knight in
let's play Knight off three now 95 wait
a minute not sure what the logic is I'll
take in than 95 okay this looks
reasonable
turning Bishop b5 I have a knight in the
center hey John Davis is here very nice
a six so not developing but stopping my
my devastating Bishop e5 threats Queen
f3 I have a couple made in one threats I
mean I should probably just open the
position like d4
that's my d4 maybe at some point C for
what to do
blocks gonna castle kind of sadly I'm
queen EE Queen e2 is too ambitious
I still play Bishop g5 now I want to
make this sharp but this might just be a
kind of a slower battle okay I have
pieces developed Queen f6 ideas maybe
I'll Castle queenside takes takes let's
maintain the pressure okay now I can
take the pawn anything else can take the
pawn and then try and hold on to the
pond in black might take back we'll see
if castling I maybe play Knight e3 Quinn
a5 let's play c3 Bishop d3
[Music]
I'm debating which side to castle still
24 is a move when a 4 to f4
I could start with any Queenie to some
like g6 ideas could be fancy castling so
nigh g6 and there's rookie Yates so
maybe I'll just Castle I think my plan
is to do this King H 1 F for rookie e1
get some what do we call this like some
kind of Pillsbury attack d4 what's d4 so
the Knights attacked I could take I take
and play 24 takes takes Queen e for
threating mates the ruck can't move
because it's stuck if g6 I take here I
mean let's do it is it gonna work
it might work the Knights from b1 came
to a3 and then just goes in a straight
almost a straight line and I think it's
gonna land on g6
oh wait that's not is it mate it's close
to me I want a sack but I don't know if
it works
takes takes takes Bishop g7 27 king f7
bishop g6 King f6 takes takes let's just
take up on first no need to calculate
when you can take upon
[Music]
still want to try and make this work I
mean I can get the rook in the end but
then black has two bishops other option
is just being a pawn and enjoying life
it's black considering Bishop f5 here
that could be a move but then Queen
takes off five it should be fine
another sub Ally thanks for subbing yeah
let's just be up upon
I'll trade Queens playoff for Bach has
bishops I have pawn I want to challenge
the file let's play a3 seems like a slow
move but I didn't want to deal with
Bishop takes a - I want to play rook c1
next I'm controlling all these squares
so there's no penetration on the C file
yeah let's play rook c1 ah smart let's
take a row just want to bring the king
in
I don't lose b2 I think I'm losing b2
unless I have tricks no I don't have
tricks that's sad
before okay let's play before I don't
want to lose more pawns play really okay
things are kind of crumbling I went from
being up a pawn to about being down a
pawn to stop Bishop c4 like I play this
so now let's play this Oh
so Black's not taking I'll but still
being tricky you have to recover with my
time I'll play this move attack the
bishop wait am i winning material here
and then d5 this might be working yeah
this is a fragile construction oh wait a
minute
forgot about that move guess I can take
take here I'll try and grind down this
ending it's gonna be a pawn race of some
sort Oh No and this move what's going on
here check and then this by winning I
might be winning it was three seconds
left about to flag but plenty of time
wow what a game when I a three Sicilian
invincible I still have to convert this
ending let's play a move get ready to
check what a game this is so stressful
every game is just a story you can write
the whole story book after this
tournament back to tournament well place
on my I'm in 308 I lost the first game
of the stream but won every single game
afterwards I started the stream at this
game okay
ooh do i beserk what's beserk that's my
rule if they're under 2,000 I'm desert
I'll play d5 playing a cm buzzer King
have to stay focused and just play my
main report or they should f4 I'll play
b6 Bishop d3 is aligned let's play 97
and I guess c5 I now the theory but I I
know I'm supposed to do stuff at some
point before Bishop e7 is actually
preparing this for the Badger blitz but
I'm forgetting most of my preparation I
just have to play quickly
let's take here if Knight takes AI of e5
of this I play against iqp play rook c8
and Queens should probably find a home
on d5
some pressure points yeah the Queen d5
okay with training rope d8 maybe a t5
double up don't think I want to trade
rooks but I might have to click Queen d5
and Queenie five ideas my throwing h6
just makes them lift oh that's a move
it's by Queen d7
yeah that's annoying move now I want to
play Knight d5 soon maybe night before
coming I have to stay focused tricky
play this move not get mated some queen
bee five ideas
I look like queen d3 it's interesting
plan okay we can trade nights it's going
to be very tough to win this so try
Bishop d6 soon I mean black should be
better with just a structure I can trade
bishops
maybe I can grind down the ending in
time I think remain really helps White's
oh I'm allowing the trade so my
advantage might kind of evaporates I'm
trading a seven for d4 I'll still have
some activity though maybe rook d5 to g5
tricky move let's do this
hitting the rook and b3 I'll play this
move oh I could have taken with Jack no
please don't see it
this is gonna play Queen c2 rook takes
with Czech trusted my opponent that's so
sad
play rip d2 had my chance
by winning I might be winning tactics
double attack threatening made into
let's go wow
I had the free rook my opponent gave me
another chance though with rook to you -
Oh stressful okay oh let's continue
let's continue
girag in ski asking do you know in the
match with wits fiddler might be I would
think in November we're supposed to
schedule a time but I'm not entirely
sure
once I know I'll be promoting it okay II
five do you play Noteboom variation was
Bishop c4 let's take I do not play the
note boom I could try it but okay not in
this game play d5 here I forget if I've
ever played the note boom just not an
opening that's I fell into my rocket or
Bishop c5 hitting the f2 pawn
okay I'm gonna lose back upon try and
get something for for my efforts not
really getting that much though
okay Queen takes was unexpected so I'm
getting development Bishop g4 coming I'm
low on time desserts no increments again
but yeah I am looking forward to playing
Sadler it should be should be a fun time
should probably start preparing let's
play this move defending the pond
rerouting the knight to the king side
[Music]
queen is almost trapped in some lines
ignite let's find out of five Queen I
was like one square on a 4-h 3 doesn't
work because I take and do stuff
also I'm winning upon Queenie a for
Bishop d7 probably looks nice the Queen
might actually get trapped Queen a 525 B
6 Queen a 6 it's very close just gonna
keep attacking the Queen is waiting for
it to get trapped Queen B 586 Queen a
for Bishop d7 if Queen c6 rookie 6 oh no
they were kings
so Queen c6 Bishop here okay I don't
have to worry about that now the queen
is trapped
oh no the Queen's not trapped there's a
square but then Bishop d6 and then the
Queen is trapped Wow such a long
sequence I have 34 seconds I still have
to I guess stay focused it took a lot of
effort
and queens only getting a minor piece we
might see resignation I could have taken
the bishop with the knight that's true
but I was more interested in the Queen
it's slightly more delicious if the
Queen somehow escaped I would have
eventually taken the bishop okay weird
move let's take a queen okay just gonna
simplify I want to get rid of this
Bishop and then attack with my own
Bishop you're threatening some force
mates not easy for it like to escape
actually I don't think there is an
escape problem with being down a queen
okay that's nice
slowly but surely let's try and break a
hundred points 93 points currently
gained a little bit of rating I think I
started the tournament I think just over
2500 okay let's not buzzer let's play e4
again I played it for most games the one
game I tried to play a London
I lost which was a the first game of the
stream okay here we have whatever we
call this panel of attack or accelerated
pattern of attack at g6 do I play
against g6
I'm just not f3 I guess Bishop c4 and
try and defend the pawn stocking b5 so
Lux black is going to try and win them
back the pawn can I defend it further I
have a Queen b3 Queen b3 could be nice
let's start with this d4 there should be
seven Queen b3
I'm just being greedy if I can hold on
to the pawn I mean these double D pawns
they control a lot of a lot of squares
in Black's territory 97 I'm not sure
what Black's trying to do maybe rook c8
totally rook e1 could play Bishop f4 go
play Bishop f4 just taking away and
controlling more squares drawing all
these squares in Black's territory
and yeah there's lots of ways to further
improve like bring the rook soon maybe
at some point 95 h3 for good measure man
the leader of this tournament has 525
points that's insane
probably started from the the beginning
d6 she always considered d6 but really
no points 95 point 95 right now but then
96 some interesting lines I think I will
go for this got you leading this and
then this and then takes takes gets
interesting and of course if takes and
my my double D pawns become too strong
Center pawns knight c6 here I could take
and I have to keep the bishop defended
there's 94 94 is interesting hmm what to
do not sure if 94 leads to much
let's do it just to occupy all the
center squares it's a cool position
maybe in 96 I can still consider this
not sure how effective it is though it's
also taking and the knight c6 takes
takes takes d5 and the end or a custom
move then I take maybe for h6 so random
play d6 here no not quite
I mean rook e1 looks
standard blacks so passive and this is a
definition of controlling the center g5
okay let's retreat this might be my
first retreating move all game every
move I've played has been I think a
forward move Knight f6 okay na f6 is
very reasonable
I play d6 here still not quite I could
take and then maybe play d6 black might
play this looks very ugly though but if
Knight takes g6 I unleash the beasts of
the battery
yeah this is just purely intuitive
there's some lines I guess to calculate
like this slimy six takes takes takes
there's some risk involved let's do it
though it looks fun the rook will be
pinned for a while there's not too many
ways for black to defend the rook only
ways to defend she really only moved his
Queen of fate and then I can take on my
mouse is falling apart I'm out of the
mouths the piece of the mouse came off
to use my trackpad now Queen digs b6 and
fixes moss okay I could take the other
rook which rook to take and also not
sure what to do yeah this is still a
little bit tricky
I've Ricky seven and some lines you like
Queen takes Ricky seven so Bishop takes
let's take up on rook c2 is gonna come
rook see - maybe Ricky - just keeping
composure aha so Ricky seven looks fun
over than 95 maybe Bishop e5 also looks
fun
Queen b5 threatening to take and win the
bishop and I also want to promote upon
the easy plan
it's nice when you're like especially in
the time trouble situation when the plan
is just pushing upon blocks going to
take and play Bishop d5 yeah
IV six at some point so I'll start with
this what to do
maybe this move play this move I want to
play d7 this should work yeah just no
risk involved okay that was nice a
little bit tricky a little bit of a
scare with my mouse breaking in the
middle of the game but that was a fun
fun middle game it's like Occupy Wall
Street but occupy Center okay
plenty of points do I have I have 97
points one more game let's say okay I
was buzzer what opening to play it's
probably what my opponent is thinking
before um let's play Sicilian d4 Smith
Maura
let's go play knight c6 e 5 so early
free pawn looks a little bit risky but
not sure if White's gonna punish me I'm
off to pawns I have initiative to should
probably be good for luck I'm in another
pond so greedy okay now the goal is not
to flag and not to get mated Queen d6
could be hurtful okay the second castle
or d5 d5 is interesting way no d5 is
probably plunders yeah let's go White
has some compensation do you have to be
careful play this move I want to put the
Queen on each five
maybe t5 first 94 ideas hmm maybe g6
darks prayers are weak but wait I was
trying to attack on the light squares I
want to play e5 soon yeah five coming oh
this is still kind of scary 25 seconds
why it's attacking from all directions
I'm still alive
that's scary move let's defend the
bishop
I wanna play Queen g7 Bishop c8 here
feel this crazy move threatening mate
and threatening the rook and threatening
the knight again threatening me oh no
I'm not threatening mates now I'm
fighting maiden three okay this is force
mates okay oh it's close to flagging
there I was getting a text
pretty much the whole game but sometimes
that's what you get for being greedy
sander Shepherd is taking off goodbye
thanks for joining
he could have checked you on each seven
as long as it's not checkmate I mean I
always had this was always defended even
and like this position if takes Queen
takes and I'm still threatening mate how
long are you gonna play the tournament
um actually that's probably my last game
for this stream
I'll probably join later for the end of
it but I I got to a hundred points I'd
play the few games last night so my my
stream started with the the kind of
depressing zero and then I I went on a
rampage but I need a break
need some coffee or some tea so thanks
guys for joining I appreciate all the
viewership as usual Kenny can you allow
things for Southern yet again I'll
probably put this on youtube as well
part 1 of 2019 autumn marathon and I
don't want to download the whole YouTube
video and then edit it and then react
sports and then upload so I'm going to
export it straight to twitch or straight
from twitch which means that when I end
the stream it will also be the end of
the YouTube video so I can say goodbye
to everyone
goodbye twitch chats goodbye John Davis
goodbye everyone else if you're watching
on YouTube subscribe like you can
comment stay tuned for part two
hopefully there will be a part two and
goodbye